hi I'm Evan Carmichael welcome to
another edition of ask Evan in today's
episode I'm going to answer a question
from one of my four meters GT who is
asking about when you're choosing a
product or service what steps should I
go through the figure out which product
or service would best suit me so GT de
atención question in my perspective I
would always start with something that
you feel really strong and passionate
about something you love something you
really believe in where you feel you can
add a unique twist or angle to if you're
not creating the product or service
yourself and you're you're reselling on
behalf of somebody else I try to find a
way that you can add your own unique
perspective or value to so for my case
whenever I'm talking about products the
products that I actually use so i have a
list on my blog that talks about all the
different products and services i use
and sometimes they'll create YouTube
videos around them my goal isn't really
to sell those products but I guess it
could be but I only promote things that
actually believe in it I actually use
and a lot of people don't do that
process to just look for whatever could
earn them the highest commission but
your best bet are building a community
around you show you an expert on
whatever topic internet marketing
whatever it is show that you're an
expert and highlight some of the tools
you use and the reasons why you believe
that they're highly effective if you can
build a community who likes hearing from
you and who wants to hear kind of the
newest product that you're into and why
and you train them on how to use it then
that could be a good opportunity for you
to be able to promote the stuff so look
at things you're passionate about loko
tools you already using and see if
there's ways that you can potentially
sell those as well if you're selling on
behalf of somebody I'd also look at what
kind of support you might get so look at
the company see if they have a program
that you can tap into if it's a referral
program see what kind of marketing
support they might give you if you kind
of left on your own or if they give you
some advice or help that could also make
an impact on you know if you're going to
choose to sell the product or not so GT
I hope that helps so there's some of the
steps I would go through I love to hear
what you guys have to think if you want
to leave a comment on the video or I
also always appreciate thumbs up if you
want to give one for the video gives me
a
kicked to the morning to want to make me
do more of these videos so thank you for
those and I love to hear from you below
and stay tuned for next episode
you